foreign
people welcome to the Honest Trailer
commentaries for the flash 2023 wow what
a long strange trip it's been but we've
arrived
um we're we're at home today uh uh
Taco's got some health health issues
that we're monitoring but he's okay
right he's okay he's okay last week uh
Taco had we we think it was a mini
stroke which apparently an older
Chihuahua's is relatively common uh he
seems to be bouncing back great he has
not had another one but I don't want to
leave him alone just a few days after he
had a stroke got it
um and also for those of you asking
Danielle Radford still uh contributing
to the show but there's some uh
confusion over exactly what is and isn't
sag uh friendly and she is a what
Associates member some kind of sag
Affiliated person she's pre-sag and it's
probably not that it's against the rules
because this isn't Studios don't pay us
to be like make fun of our movies when
they hit vot so this isn't directly a
promotional anyway but it's I think it's
close enough that she was a little yeah
out of an abundance of coffee Daniel
Radford sends her regards uh but we will
keep you posted on that and uh on the
strike and um Stephen amell's thoughts
on uh
he just walked it back yeah a publicist
got to him first thing this morning and
so now he's saying like I noticed him he
is pointing out he was like on stage for
an hour answering questions it wasn't
like this was a statement he made to the
Press he he may have just misspoken in
the moment on state but yeah he's
totally walking back supports the union
supports the strike you'll see him on
the picket line uh he has not failed
this city
well speaking of mistakes and flubs and
things that people wish they could have
walked back The Flash 2023. oh my gosh
now this is a much maligned movie for a
lot of reasons
um and it's been uh in development for
at least eight years maybe longer
um or we've been reporting on it for at
least eight years we've been you and I
have personally been talking about it
for at least eight years now and it's
finally here
um and it's amazing that this is the
version that actually that actually came
out
um I will say that obviously this got
trashed and everybody hated it uh or
that was the word on the street for me
walking in and I liked the first 30
minutes of this movie I thought it was
ridiculous I'm like oh he's putting
babies in the microwave this is this is
silly and stupid on purpose that's kind
of fun it's like a big cartoon this is a
bunch of different movies all put
together like it's obvious that there
were like every concept they had during
the last 10 years for a Flash movie like
at least or two of it got into this and
I will say I agree with you the the
movie that feels like it's just like the
Snyder verse is ongoing where it's just
a bunch of DC heroes teaming up they're
working together to stop crimes got them
from some like a building is collapsing
oh we'll get into that reason uh so but
that's the worst at least it's it's
better because it feels more just like a
superhero story you know like problem in
the city they gotta save people they
gotta team up they got to use their
powers like that's kind of what the you
know that's the bread and butter stuff
yeah so
um from the time he goes into the terror
Dome onwards which I believe is around
minute 30. the Chrono Bowl the Chrono
get it right
it was really downhill from there so
um I don't know I almost feel I think we
should just launch right and if you
haven't uh we're gonna do deleted scenes
we're gonna do q a so put those uh in
the chat as they come in and then we'll
tease you with next week's honest
trailer which is um it's a real
three-way competition for the worst
superhero Thing of the year yeah the
race is heating up we did just to get
just to get we did quantumania which I
was sure when we did it was like well
I'm not gonna hate any comic book thing
more than this this year we've been
blasted into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
um
but then yeah uh this week's uh flash is
like wow maybe maybe this even takes the
crowd and then next week is is even
another Contender it's crazy it's
getting out of hand wild time for um for
every every superhero uh content creator
because man if you were liking if you're
just uncritically liking the Flash
quantumania and next week's thing
I know Studios don't pay influencers and
people but I just wonder what type of
brain leads you to like what's been
coming out recently of these three
things uh one out of three sure two out
of three uh but if you like all three
things we're we're talking about wow
okay well we I I I want to so yeah
consult your consult your physician yeah
uh you know
let's see what's uh let's see what's on
the docket we'll we'll stop and start as
it goes because this is a long movie and
I think we'll have a lot to say about it
so let's watch the Australia oh my God
eight hours right eight and a half hours
something like that
it's not like I can show up
you've seen Ezra Miller star in bar
fights restraining orders grooming
allegations felony burglaries and
chokeslam videos did you wanna fight
know now see the film that dares you to
wonder what dirt Ezra has on Warner
Brothers because this is basically
confession tape
of aim Sleek is not very good at that
part yet trust me
The Flash so pause I just feel like with
Ezra Miller so many people have been
fired for so much less
uh or removed from projects it's also
and and look don't take this the wrong
way obviously on-screen Talent
horrible things you do off-screen
they're not connect I'm not suggesting
one should depend on the other but
just just
you would think
anyone who is this much of a Troublesome
presence
they would just be an on-screen Dynamo
it would be a A-list celebrity that's
like opens a movie uh just on their face
alone plus you know like like just the
most dynamic presence like well we can't
not include this person audiences the
camera loves them yeah how are we gonna
replace Clarence from the Fantastic
Beasts movie but it seems like and
never given a good like I you know we
need to talk about Kevin good movie
they're solid in that one but it's like
these aren't the kinds of performances
no other actor could give you could put
a lot of people in this Twitchy nebishy
constantly motor mouth burialis wasn't
what practically all the rules are
anyway everybody's a sarcastic motor
mouth in movies in 2023. I just don't
get why it has to be this one person
certainly it's not because they were
spending all that time on the CGI like
oh well we can't start over we'd have to
make a a completely different set of uh
lump in monstrosities coming up yeah
coming out of the Chrono Bowl we'll talk
about the corona bowl and why it looks
like that later I guess but yeah
they're annoying in this movie and
you're like well they're annoying
already
this is bringing somebody who's less
annoying also not a criminal but less
annoying too I feel like they had
options given the amount of time other
times and ways they pivoted on this
movie that they were like but we're
riding with Ezra to The Bitter End and
um bitter as a the very end wait wait
till he turns full wait till they turn
full Simon Phoenix just taking over
entire buildings in downtown L.A
hijacking buses
I put watch Ezra Miller in a Demolition
Man uh in the Simon Phoenix role who
plays Josh Barton
I think he'll do um no um
uh who's the I'm an [__] guy the
Denis Leary role all right okay yeah
yeah all right keep let's keep going
Edgar friendly yes we're James Gunn
reboots the DC Cinematic Universe for
the sixth time seventh I lost count to
the Finish Line with this colossal
screw-up all about a colossal screw-up I
am pretty obnoxious let's burn through
directors like the weed on Ezra's Ranch
where they found a one-year-old with a
bullet in her mouth allegedly allegedly
the concept of the Multiverse about 10
years too late to be interesting he's
Gonna Save The Multiverse yeah man then
the Multiverse there are an infinite
number of people who know Peter Parker
is Spider-Man
idiots
the Warner Brothers server verse that's
almost self-aware about how sloppy and
stale the concept is
what it is
a hot mess but that won't stop them from
using it to defile the corpse of some
Legends to make a quick buck
it's enough to make you lose faith in
humanity oh Faith restored rare W
Humanity rare W so I mean what's your
theory for why this was as big of a
failure at the box office because they
certainly went all out with uh with the
promotion they had people they trotted
out every everyone they could be big but
they've destroyed his reputation it's
obscene yeah uh why why didn't people
believe them why didn't they show up I
think we're in this era where you know
for for many many years leading into the
pandemic uh you know the idea was the
way to get people to the theater was
name recognition Brands you know like
you might not show up for a random
superhero movie but the flash from the
DC movies from the Justice League we've
seen those characters you know that
franchise are gonna come out and that
like and that's why everything is you
know fast X and the mission impossible
dead reckoning whatever and for whatever
reason I think it's a few different
factors I definitely think streaming and
the idea that these episodic franchises
you can always just check in the latest
episode on streaming and audiences just
got used to the it's starting to feel
less like I have to get out to the
theater every time to see every new
installment when there's going to be 10
20 installments I'll just wait for
Netflix or or whatever I think that was
a big part of it and I think also we're
just no longer in that era of people
going to the theater just to go to the
theater you got to get them sure yeah
you got to get them out specifically
they're gonna come see this thing that
you've sold them on very specifically
there's no more just like well this is
the number we'll go see what's it what's
playing at three and we'll go check out
the Flash and I think
a lot of these franchises were kind of
riding on that sort of energy and that
doesn't exist anymore so yeah I think I
I you know I think this didn't do enough
to really sell people on this is going
to be different than all of the other
superhero movies that you've seen I mean
at this point cameos and the Nostalgia
stuff and the Legacy stuff is in every
movie so I don't even think that makes
it stand out as much as it might have
five years ago yeah and their selling
point you know say what you will about
the Schneider verse but at least it
wasn't ethos uh but we'll see I mean it
uh it had it that selling point of like
if this is the next installment of a
franchise like you wanted to see the
next installment but people the people
who were clued in knew that this was all
getting flushed down the toilet anyways
yeah so there was no point there's
nothing coming later I guess Aquaman too
but really there's no reason to uh
invest in this to continue the journey
because you know it's all about to get
reset and and the last thing I'll say
and this dovetails with uh the sort of
failure of Indiana Jones this summer too
as I think that uh executives are doing
some of the age on their Nostalgia math
wrong
I think that a guy like Indy and a guy
like Michael Keaton Batman have a lot of
appeal you got to be like
close to my age to remember like those
are both well to remember the good times
yeah well those are both 89 move Last
Crusade in Batman 89. you know yeah if
you're under 40 you you don't remember
those movies in theaters that's those
are old movies for you and I think man
you know you're relying on old guys to
drive it too much like you gotta aim you
gotta eight work like 80s Nostalgia is
done man you got we gotta jump to the
90s I mean the fact that they didn't
it's a huge misread for the the
marketing that they didn't focus on Ben
Affleck rather than Michael Keaton right
and if you're gonna do a Batman first
promo yeah you're selling the dads when
you're selling Michael Keaton Batman not
not the kids and and I don't think you
can make a movie like The Flash and make
500 million dollars if you're just
selling the the dads I mean maybe like
top gun Maverick but not not the flash
yeah
um okay let's keep going you do when
your store goes on a massive crime spree
cast them twice wait that can't be right
three times what is going on Barry Allen
one is a whiny little thanks for saving
me from the sinkhole Flash and I'm
starving and curly hair girl isn't here
and her name is Sarah and she has a
boyfriend
you hear that that's my stomach but
after his mom is murdered by someone I
guess Barry who works in a forensic
crime lab didn't bother to check in on
that part he'll reverse time the murder
of Mary's mother is bizarrely glossed
over I would say considering how pivotal
a plot point it is like was it a hit
yeah well you yeah I mean it feels like
in Another Universe this movie is him
solving his mom like that's an
afterthought he's like very worried
about his dad not getting convicted
because he knows his dad is Innocent but
he's not very big on who did this and
you would think that would be because
that would also if you figured out who
did it that also gets your your dad out
of prison so like it's weird that
thumbs up that like he's not even like
on the phone to cereal like hey I got a
great case you know like it's just not
even a consideration and the the murder
itself makes no sense it's it's she was
in her kitchen and in a night somebody
first on it was an empty house and ran
in stabbed her and ran no yeah ran and
planning to rob an entire house saw a
woman there with a kitchen knife and
panic because of oh my God uh Maribel
Verdu armed with a kitchen knife my
plans are foiled uh so it stabs her
murders her in her own kitchen and then
runs out without even stealing anything
no evidence leaving no evidence not a
fingerprint not a footprint
and and and that's that's the entire
crime that's all we know about it it's
very strange I think that they were
gonna reveal that to be you know reverse
flash or it's a Gorilla Grodd or
something like that but I I think
they're relieving that for the first I
really should have been here but the
fact that he never even like scratched
the surface of who may have done that
because certainly that's what the whole
movie in John the whole movie's about
and he's it there's a person out there
in the world who ruined your life he
killed your your mother while you were
in the house while your dad was gone and
then let your dad go to jail like he's
not even angry about that he's just
upset about oh my dad's gonna you know
rot away in prison forever yeah if I can
only find the the yeah he goes back in
time to like switch the tomatoes like no
go back in time to like uh kick the the
murderer into the Sun or even hang out
outside your house and watch who goes in
follow that guy home and now you know
who killed your mom yeah uh all right
Flash too we'll see the True Crime
podcast growing up with two parents
somehow made him more obnoxious
[Laughter]
and now the storm's gonna ruin my day
what is this hell now I'm probably gonna
have to move why is it so cold it's the
Arctic bearing okay and the space Giant
and mistress murder are our
responsibility too I was just doing my
love you're the one the difference
between them is very odd and I don't
fully understand how having a two-parent
household would make you that annoying
and isn't it implied that Barry one is a
virgin but Berry too
he says it yeah he comes out and says
that he's he's and and Ezra Miller I
don't know about Barry Allen Ezra Miller
30 years old Barry Allen maybe we could
say a few years cut a few years off of
that but that's he's getting up there
right yeah it was it was very strange
um uh why is that the lasso of Truth
Wonder Woman has the last bit of Truth
around Barry and then he admits that
he's never had yeah yeah but the other
one is like going on dates and like has
a girlfriend and well he's going on a
date we don't go on a date we have not
confirmed there there is you know maybe
who knows what were the what were the
movie posters on it they had some
interesting paraphernalia on his uh on
his house I noticed one was just a
sticker that said new metal which is how
you really know you're gonna like a
character yeah I just love the genre
that's what the kids were into man
he had a he had a um
Inception poster I think that's right so
again because time timey wimey you know
yeah that fits in yeah
um and then like yeah just be
Marvel's guilty this too it's like the
lack of creativity in imagining a
Multiverse and all the possibilities
like the biggest thing they can come up
with is like different movie castings
they're like oh my God Eric Stoltz is
Back to the Future and like different
names like they're like banana bees like
that's as far as it goes or Marvel where
it's like pizza comes in a ball yeah you
can do anything and they just use it to
kind of reshuffle who's wearing which
super suit right and and and
it really kind of cheapens the entire
Multiverse concept which is so Broad and
makes so many different storytelling
possibilities you know in in the you
know in the mix and then yeah like to
just make it like well here the red
lights are green and the green it's like
you remember that show sliders that's
what it of course yeah whatever episode
of Sliders would be like it's just like
our universe but Elvis never existed and
I was like I feel like that damn it so
close right I mean like that's the take
and and and you know once or twice as a
joke as a gag is a bit sure fine but
we're getting that at the point where
it's just okay we keep redoing
Multiverse and then it's the same
concept over and over again even down to
this movie and across the spider verse
both do the same across the spider
versus a lot better I'm not making that
comparison but they're both through the
like there are you can't really change
things in the Multiverse because there
are these like moments that have to
happen
yeah oh boy Canon events yeah
we're using the Multiverse to
continually tell the exact same story
it's not even the multiverses themselves
are similar the the narratives are
similar like why like do something else
with it yeah maybe he can change things
in this one let's try it you know
we've just we've just flubbed uh the
whole concept like writ large I think
it's time to just tie a bow in it
um no more Multiverse movies at this
point it's just it's boring to now when
I when I could feel a franchise going
that way I get kind of bored I I want
there to be because I want there to be
more Stakes I want there to be one
practical reality it makes stories more
involving yeah and and there it's like
what six could be bigger than like all
of existence every timeline's like well
that's so big that I don't
I'm jumping ahead in this movie but you
also end up with with this scenario
where what actually happens to the
reality in which this movie takes place
like oh it's gone it's a sliders ending
we're like oh wait the the Golden Gate
Bridge is blue like I guess it's still
not home so none of it matters none of
it mattered but I mean like yeah we're
spending the whole movie fighting on
behalf of a universe that vaporizes I
mean that that version of Supergirl is
gone for she's murdered by sod and then
we take off from that universe and like
oh I should never have created this
universe to begin with like well yeah
but now there's billions of people
living in it wasn't it funny that George
Clooney showed up and then his tooth
fell out right but does that mean that
that the Ben Affleck universe that the
the franchise spent its entire existence
in all of those also gone yeah so we're
we're dead like we we the viewers lived
in the Ben Affleck version of the DC
Universe so now we're gone I don't know
if that's the one we are living in right
now
I thought we were living in the Robert
Pattinson Batman Universe currently is
that where the franchise started he's
jumped out of the franchise's own
Universe into a new universe and left
the franchise behind yes it's over I
think it's officially dead and now we're
in the Batman room blue beetles gotta
still happen back there
I guess guys the only Blue Beetle behind
no James gonna said if people like Blue
Beetle he gets to come in he's he's part
of the new one he'll get if people like
blue beetles only if people like him if
people don't like him he's ouch but no
if fans want he'll he gets to come along
into the Superman Legacy verb that means
that that this is going to be one of the
more self-contained installments of of
anything oh sure if he's leaving the
door open like sure George Lopez has
that joke about Batman being a fascist
that's probably about it
yeah we'll see we'll see uh all right
let's keep going and told me that I'm a
superhero what are you doing would you
stop whining and gross
it's a bit more loose it hurts you know
where it hurts
in my dick okay was Grant Gustin that
unavailable I'm a Christopher Plummer
Weird Al but there he's not alone and
thank goodness because two and a half
hours of this would be a war crime you
don't stop talking it's not Charming
it's abrasive and exhausting Michael
Keaton is back as a very 71 year old
Batman this might hurt when he's not
playing the hits with all the enthusiasm
of Smash Mouth at a County Fair I'm
Batman how much do you wait you want to
get nuts
let's get nuts dads are stomping their
new balances and making him eat
repeatedly
oh there's a weird choice for a film
that clearly wants to be a bad man movie
instead they even go full Clooney Tunes
at the end
I like that he's banished to the Batman
and Robin verse now that feels earned
cool so yeah boss
it's one thing to bring back uh Michael
Keaton's Batman but or in this reality
but it's just it was so incongruous with
the movie that he was in that it never
felt like you were watching Michael
Keaton's Batman they don't they don't do
even there's not even one moment where
you get a flash of the classic Bruce
Wayne we know and love from from Batman
and Batman Returns it feels like a
totally different and depressing take on
the character like did we really see
like Gotham at all really I mean I guess
it's his manner right they drive they
take first of all they take a cab to
Gotham they get out without paying which
was insane so there's a deleted scene
there yeah uh but you they pull up
outside the manor and then we don't see
the Tim Burton we never see the Tim
Burton take German expressionist Gotham
we don't even go there no no it's just
like one of those things where seeing
Batman in the daytime much less like an
empty Battlefield like he just looks
silly it's just not a good it's also big
we get a they unveil the Batmobile but
then we never see it in action we see
the bat wing but it's obviously
different from the one from the 80s
because he's spinning it does this spin
around move now so it's like they don't
even give us the Baseline like this is
what you remember they give you the
dialogue but none of the visuals
aesthetically this looks nothing like
well because if you take that Batman
that Batmobile down the streets of
Central City which I'm sure is Vancouver
or Georgia or yeah it just looks dumb
it's like a promotional yeah but it
you have to think about these things
like movies are visual I can't believe
I'm on a show and I have to say that out
loud
but if you're going to integrate the 89
Batman with your new movie you have to
kind of design your new movie with that
in mind because it has a very specific
aesthetic because you know
Tim Burton right I know what he does
that's sort of his whole bit but also
what what these people love doing and
this is another clue for next week is
that they love bringing people in who
you love and then calling them old and
washed up and pathetic and then killing
them
that's movies these days yeah and like
sometimes you know like Logan or
whatever like I get it the whole movie's
built around that idea Dorian and he's
going to have this Redemptive moment at
the end but yeah this one is just a it's
just a real bummer it's just he's just
old and he can't be Batman anymore and
he's he's really trying his best but
it's not working out for him and then
they just smash the bat wing into the
side of a force field and then and then
kill him a couple more times for good
measure why did you think we'd want to
see this this isn't Fun give them like a
moment of heroism I don't know I guess
he's fine he has one fight um but he he
does all right in against some Russian
power plant guards but let's get on to
Supergirl there's some interesting stuff
there too yeah keep going when Barry
forgets that generals out attacked the
day after he got his powers briefly
Sasha cow comes to save the day both in
the movie and outside of it since Ezra
was presumably locked in the WB water
tower for the entire press tour in this
brand new take on a Kryptonian a grim
tortured Soul who questions whether
humanity is even worth fighting for oh
right well this time baby soups got
snuffed out of his crib so it's even
Grimmer the infant did not survive
so strapless
yeah there was the oh my God that was
the most zoomed in performance yet he
said did you see he did an interview
where he's like ah I don't know they had
me come back for a few days I can't
connect oh he he dropped a couple uh uh
some shade about this or he's saying
like well the Man of Steel like there
was something going on for the character
in this one I'm more of like just there
to kind of move things forward kind of
move the plot forward
um but yeah Sasha cat I I thought she
was there's there's something
interesting going on there like they had
a good start like okay what if Superman
what what if it was his cousin uh and
she uh was like kept in a cage instead
of you know growing up and in the old uh
paw Kent Farm like how that would change
you're like that's a good origin story
for a Grimmer a grim Dark Superman or
Supergirl or Superwoman or whatever and
uh
they just didn't give her anything yeah
they didn't play with the concept really
she was just like pissed off she goes
out in the sun she tries to fight Zod
she dies
yeah again we we've said it before like
this whole movie is like obviously six
ideas for Flash movies grafted awkwardly
onto one another and yeah I mean this
one probably would have been one of the
better ones like the the idea of him
teaming up like Batman Flash and
Supergirl teaming up to repel an alien
invasion sure why not I could have
watched that she's doing fine like it
seems like a cool take on the character
but it's such an afterthought in this
movie that mission is like just this one
little part of this larger
framework it doesn't really get a lot of
development on its own it's hard to
really invest in her that character
what's going on because it's we know
that it doesn't matter this is just one
of many realities Barry's gonna run in
and out of and there's no real Stakes to
this fight and it doesn't ultimately
matter so yeah I mean like
it it's it's certainly not on her fault
or the character or anything but it
there's not really that much here to
hang your hat on well it's just like
they give her a villain's origin story
like they give her every reason to be on
zod's side so it was it just was strange
that she's I felt like the plot said
that she had to be good so she was
there's so little to it I mean she's got
you know two or three kind of quickie
scenes and it's it's sort of barely even
a character really yep oh well next week
we didn't already know Kara zorrell if
Supergirl wasn't a pre-existing concept
you'd have no you'd have you know no
context for her whatsoever just based on
this movie
uh well that's I think that's all we're
getting which is a shame because this
would have been the one thing I kept
from the flesh but all right that's
Multiverse Anything Can Happen uh let's
keep going he did film that looks like
it was rendered on a GameCube with the
least realistic baby since Clint
Eastwood's prop guy took a sick day
featuring monstrous digital stand-ins
huge balls of ghoulish fan service for
40 year olds and the first Hollywood
action climax set entirely on a Halo 3
map you know I'm starting to think all
of Warner Brothers is elaborate tax
write-off now like the producers under
the right circumstances a producer could
make more money with a flop than he
could with a hit or Infinity train or
bad girl or face five or so yeah pause I
don't think I I think to the country
they actually expected The Flash to be a
billion dollar movie which shows you the
Instinct yeah people in charge right now
yeah I mean all of this is working on
you know 2018 math when when all of
these movies were coming out they were
juggernauts you know one after another
all because people were really into the
franchise and the storytelling you know
the long-form storytelling I just think
we're in a very different
cultural moment right now and people
want
you know they they want more interesting
special like I'm gonna go out to a
theater it's got to be something unique
and and you know interesting that's uh
that works on its own
but the effects and then I can take a
picture of myself with the screen and
the background and annoy everyone around
me so everyone on Instagram knows that I
saw it right the the effects though we
we kind of glossed over that because
they are maybe my biggest takeaway from
the film and I know that these places
are incredibly overworked and underpaid
and like pushed to their absolute limit
but then the director came out and said
no that's exactly what it's supposed to
look like yeah I I think this is what we
need to talk about this idea that that
oh no they're supposed to look distorted
like sure yes varies in the these his
world is Warped and distorted by the
time field and and we all get that we
all get that nobody's confused about why
there's like lights and weird Shimmer
and whatever but there's no excuse it
just it just looks bad it looks it looks
half rendered like if that's your visual
aesthetic
come up with a different visual
aesthetic like that's not an excuse like
oh it looks bad on purpose like well
then make it look good on purpose what
are you doing it's a movie
we're actually talking about
um last week about it's Andy machete
right yes like how he was the he was the
cleanup guy for it chapter two right
well it I mean he he worked on both
chapters but it was it was Corey
fukunaga was directing the hit movies
and then only did one and then there was
you know two contents of development
issues and whatever and then yeah Andy
machete managed to like come in and
clean up and get the movie out on time
on you know relatively on budget I guess
or whatever and then he did that again
like they had you know 12 different
directors attached to various points and
he kind of came in got whether or good
or bad got a movie finished and
releasable and out you know so like he's
yeah he's becoming that guy like so he's
been but he's been reward we're trying
to figure out why he's been given you
know a new Batman movie and why
everybody's right so high on him because
it's like he's like the wolf in Pulp
Fiction like you've made it you've made
a huge mess of things and he will come
in and just like get it done and get it
he's gonna Michael Clayton your project
and like scrape together this disaster
and get something releasable together so
you can move forward and save face
exactly I mean I really do think that on
some level he's becoming like a fixer
kind of director yeah that's a real gig
like that you need a guy like that you
know that's right that's right and and
another reason why I would love a um
like either a docu-series or a
dramatization of you know the making of
the flag more so than the flesh itself I
used to know when I worked at the video
store we had a guy I won't do his thing
because I don't know if he'd appreciate
that we just have a regular customer who
came in and he worked for Disney Walt
Disney pictures but he he never like
wrote a movie himself he was the last
guy in the line so like when something
like snow dogs and they'd have to
rewrite it a bunch of times and then
Cuba Gooding Jr comes in and he wants to
rewrite a bunch of times like the last
guy this was the last guy on the line
who would take everybody else's notes
and like Stitch it all together and come
up with like the coherent beginning to
end screenplay and that was his whole
job and he did it for like every Disney
live action movie wow and that explains
why they're all so good yeah so that's
like Andy machete he's like the last
director on the line he takes everybody
else's ideas like all right we gotta get
rid of this thing and not enough time
for Supergirl we gotta I need I need
three more days with Michael Shannon and
he comes out with a releasable finished
product yeah I mean from that
perspective it is a miracle that that
anything exists that anything comes
together when when these movies are true
Frankenstein monsters these these giant
corporate things that are like made out
of the the worst ideas of 18 different
people uh half of them film Executives
and somebody at the end of the day has
to get from A to B to Z yeah um and
that's that's a success and I feel like
you can you can sort of tell watching
this what a what a mess it was and how
much work he had to do to make like okay
well we've got this 20 minute segment
here
it does not match this 20-minute segment
here what goes here to make this part go
into this part and like that's that's
not easy to do no I'm not saying it
makes a good movie but right it happened
it got done you know it's I was just
reading about uh like Christopher Nolan
having to like convince so many people
at Warner Bros like why he did
everything in in Batman Begins
um and it's just like he sent them like
edited together montages of other movies
to show them why their notes were wrong
God it's brutal
um all right let's wrap this up the
perks of being a wall phaser
beers beers beers Naked and Afraid let's
do the time warp again I'm not sure what
I'm doing here something to do with a
flash I think Been There Done That I Am
Sasha Fierce nap before Zod what exactly
would you say it as you do here E2 Mama
I'm dead West Side Story Superman the
quest to rest in peace face looks off
galga Cameo Curry worst and this is what
a 200 million dollar movie looks like
now I guess can't believe they did it
again
yeah
floating heads if three flashes three
Batman four kryptonians Aquaman and one
Roman can drive ticket sales Warner
Brothers is gonna need a new hero to
save the box office
Come on Barbie
let's go party
bingo
well there you go I I think that so
we've got Aquaman two we got Blue Beetle
and Aquaman too and that'll and then the
the James Gunn stuff is next so
hopefully we'll get a breather
um 2025 is Superman Legacy so for the
next year we've only got like these kind
of two wrap it up projects for the next
year and a half other than TV I mean
obviously there's lots of TV but like
yeah movies uh yeah live action
obviously there's animated movies but
but yeah and then and then 2025 Superman
Legacy we restart with the whole new
no-ho hang oh but don't forget uh the
other verse is um you know uh joke or
two
all right there's still there's still
all these standalones Joker two and then
our bats whatever they're working on
next for him there's that penguin show
that they're doing I guess filming got
interrupted by the strikes but Colin
Farrell's at least part way through
filming that penguin show yeah well I
think a year or more off while they kind
of rethink and get their ducks in a row
is just enough time for Zack Snyder to
come back you know it's in the works
this has all been uh a big big
machination a twist ending that Nolan is
right did you see Barbie the the
have you seen yes the incredible Zack
Snyder joke they managed to sneak in
there one of the highlights of the film
I thought
I will uh we'll we'll we'll movie fight
that one um later is the The Godfather
one we'll talk about that okay yeah
um all right so that's uh that's that
thank god oh man it's rough tie a bow on
flash for a long time
um thank y'all for watching I don't know
they're just like
they look gross I don't
I don't want an Ant-Man like they're
literally like nauseating I don't like
the way they look there's something that
makes me uncomfortable about looking at
them if I don't work as a I mean yeah if
they don't work as visual spectacle
you're you're left with just the plot
and the and the sheer uh just a
character is on the screen that I
recognize that's all there is to them
without like good action that's all
that's left and that's not what it is
Mary running through the the Chrono the
running looked bad right how do you get
that running to look back but then
you're seeing these like plastic fake
like human faces that are sort of like
two ex too much expression they're all
kind of glossy it's like polar expressed
or whatever and it's just like I just
don't like it I don't know there's
something I can't even describe it's
visceral I just don't like it yeah I
think that they were on to something
even though it looked
ugly uh was the baby shower is like Okay
so this you're doing like a Looney Tunes
movie where he's a roadrunner and it's
like like have him running into things
that uh somebody Zod has painted to look
like a tunnel yeah yeah but I mean like
it's actually not wand uh there's that
joke where they run over the two little
dogs and they're like flattened on the
sidewalk and they needed to redo that
that they they reshot that because the
original focus group audiences they made
it look too realistic and audiences
freaked out over the dead dogs and so I
think it was that like if you had the
babies look too real we would have a
moment like everybody would tense up
like oh baby but you have to make them
look kind of cartoonish so it's funny
but they notice that my rewatch is that
um that uh Nursery worker or I don't
know what what type of nurse uh that is
but she she's going out uh with the baby
and she Chucks that baby out there yeah
I think she's on her way up and she's
like
she's gonna need her arms free to brace
for her own impact got it think about it
yeah
maternal instincts not not the strongest
with that one she that she tosses that
baby hard that's a work baby that's not
her bit that's a work baby
uh all right so uh uh we're gonna move
on to the next section of uh of outtakes
and uh q a but um not before that
happens but after that happens you
should definitely check out our uh
Ode to character actors our musical uh
our musical guide that's on uh on this
channel that came out yesterday that we
thought was just a fun thing to do so so
hope you enjoy that and we were watching
something where there were a lot of
notable bad guys actors in it that's
what prompted the idea I feel yeah yeah
um so please uh if you enjoy stuff like
that like we like to sprinkle in some
fun things in between us trailers so we
we have some more ones uh along those
lines coming soon that that we'll see if
we can pull up
um and yeah yeah so check that out and
then uh come right back here so let's
watch some outtakes if we got him but
after the tragic loss of gal gadot's
dialect coach not every problem has a
solution
but after a tragic loss caused by Mom's
spaghetti
starring we got a runner mother boy we
need to talk about Ezra young Barry
Better Than Ezra let's get paid bad
daddy Krypton currency Ron Livingston I
presume paper girl Scoops MC mean c
drunkies
DC's Kingdom Dom Dumb and Dumber when
Barry met Freud back to the drawing
board the slider butt
yeah that wasn't mine but I'm assuming
sure refers to
all right let's go on to uh the Q a so
Bruins fan 1144 how did Warner Brothers
convince Tom Cruise to endorse this
movie so strongly he needs to get a
state and levels checked out he is not
clear I think probably probably he just
loves Cinema so much that he'll
encourage anyone to see anything in in a
theater right I I think there was
definitely whether it was official or
not there seemed to be like a everybody
was going to help promote everybody
else's movie this summer like everybody
kind of recognizes his joint effort
Hollywood's got to come together and
sell people on going to the theater so
you know Greta and Margo got their
tickets to Oppenheimer and I think I
think it was part of that Spirit if
everybody was just going to go out and
support everybody else's so plus Tom
just he's not that discriminating Tom
just loves moves I I feel like Tom loves
everything he sees on the big screen
he's really psyched about pretty much
everything he does he just has a good
time in the theater yeah
um so we have two questions from frog
eater and Al Patrickson uh imploring us
to do
um the Clone Wars TV show on his trailer
for Ahsoka and I don't want to I have
other we have so many other things that
are coming out to do we will don't don't
get it twisted we will but I think it's
going to take longer than three weeks
because we have next weeks and then the
week after that is we can't miss and
then uh we're working on other projects
that are also coming out and it's like
that it's such a long show
it's not that I hate it so much it's
just a long that's that's that's all
it's it's doing multi-season TV shows
like that is like a whole huge thing
yeah I think you know sometimes we're
able to bring in people to help with the
with the TV show like we did for Doctor
Who and stuff like that doctor who was
not even remotely possible come on
that's been on for a thousand years yeah
before they invented TV they were making
documents let's see what uh Mr Merle's
up to kick the tires on that and uh
maybe we can get a get a ringer to to
start working on Clone Wars because uh
the next we'll do it but not it's not
gonna happen in the next three weeks
It's never enough we'll do it and then
immediately it'll just be like now do
Rebels like we'll never we'll never get
away we'll never get free well what
about kidnap sock maybe he's uh that's
great he would be great he would kill it
yeah but we need to at least watch
enough of it to like to to put it a lot
you have not you haven't seen Clone Wars
I've seen a bunch of it I've seen all of
it but I've seen a lot yeah it's in
discussion we'll discuss
um all right so uh I'm a new Disney plus
Star Wars show comes out there's a list
of here's the Thousand Clone War
episodes you have to watch just to catch
up you're not gonna know who bocatan is
uh if we got an extended Cameo from
Henry Cavill in the flash would it have
improved the movie or just rub salt in
the wounds uh
I don't know if any single Cameo could
have improved this I do think that the
entire film looked like his mouth um
from the weed and cut of Justice League
like they pointed to the mouth and said
we want everything to look like that so
I don't think it would have been good I
mean he's in this in the same way that
all the other cameos are in it in that
he's he's there in the Chrono bowl like
yeah his like Injustice uh yeah looking
body is charging out yeah looking
looking mucusy and uh but that's that
but that's that's how Christopher Reeves
Cameo is or Helen Slater's Cameo or
Nicholas Cage so like if we're
considering that a cameo he cameos like
like yeah would it have been nice to see
him like in context as Superman as part
of the story sure but like it would have
been nice to see Michael Keaton's Batman
in context as part of the story as well
but
not this time yeah
uh Pat magana asked you blonde um now
that we're halfway through 2023 what's
this year's best red notice
ooh what is this year's number one
that's a great question I'm gonna pull
up my list just so I don't it's gonna
say ghosted
was a red notice yeah go ghost it is is
probably my pick yeah I I think I think
we're going with ghosted I think that's
the the most read noticey film of this
year there's only been there have been
fewer this year than than last year but
yeah wow ghosted good good Lord just and
it was it was so like it hit it exactly
on the nose like you know there's that
like Globe trotting but you don't really
ever get a sense for different places
it's just like we're in eight different
locations so it goes to there's like one
see where Chris Evans runs up a
Roosevelt mountain and we spin the
camera around and then there's just a
little subtle hyper pass like that's the
most red noticey thing there could
possibly be yeah no we're in the kyber
pass folks look how Sandy it is
okay off to the next location that's
going on the red notice bingo card for
sure is kyber pass today do we swing by
the kyberpet Yeah uh slavaton Rock asks
is there someone from the Snyder era
that you would bring into guns DC
no I mean listen I I like a lot of those
I think I think the best thing Zack
Snyder did overall in in his time was
casting like the casting's really good
and I like a lot of those people so yeah
there's there's a bunch there's there's
a bunch I'd bring over probably yeah
they're all they're all great Jeremy
Irons
um I even I don't know I don't love
Germany it's like two
I don't know he's not he doesn't feel
like a butler to me he feels like Bruce
Wayne's like project manager or
something like he's never really been a
yeah there's he's pretty I want 12
Spectrum yeah yeah I want 10 more
bottling from from Jeremy I he's always
just like the he's like the guy in the
chair I'm like no no he's gotta
occasionally be dusting something in the
background that's just that's just
that's just part of the Alfred story
you must occasionally does yeah yeah
uh let's see Russell Crowe as as uh
jorel was so good I might if you're ever
if we ever need a jorel in the gun verse
I think you hard to know that he gave
the best speech in the entire Snyder
verse I think yeah um I really like that
join me in the sun
um all right so James Bond says what
movie should be the poster child for
Insider lying about how good the movie
is I can't remember many other instances
I'm sure they're out there of like not
fake hype but but uh a campaign where
everybody they somehow get everybody to
tell you that this is the best movie
they've ever seen and it yeah it's not I
don't remember marketing campaigns quite
like that but this was this is very
wide-ranging people are bringing up um
that they got uh hideo Kojima to chime
in about how great it was uh James Gunn
obviously saying is amazing and yeah
Stephen King Tom Cruise
yeah yeah yeah Liars
uh so rapid fire ones benzai 10 are you
excited for the Meg too yes yes I am you
know I did not really like Meg one I
found it sort of underwhelming based on
how fun the premise sounded but big two
is Ben Wheatley did you notice the guy
who did like free fire and I'm excited I
think meg2's got a surprise surprise
some people I mean um
yeah and Ben Wheatley doing it makes me
think there must be something really
cool and interesting about it or he
wouldn't do it you know yeah uh and then
we'll end with this Reynard City update
channel uh what Universe would you
prefer to live in the one where stove
pipe hats are always in fashion or the
universe where custard creams are
currency
I would go with the stove pipe hat
always in fashion because I wouldn't
want to have to carry like a pocket full
of cream anytime I wanted to pay for
something and I I feel like this might
be a UK term or that what is a custard
cream I'm assuming it's some type of
disgusting British food that's like a
slop yeah like I know what custard is
and I know what cream is and they seem
like they're the same thing so using
both yeah it's what I thought it would
be it's just a big thing of slop
um sweet sweet and slop I'm sure uh or
well no it's a it's a it's a cookie or a
biscuit if you will maybe a custard
cream I I don't want to answer unless I
know what it is
yeah okay okay so just like a filling
that you would get in like a pastry like
a okay uh yeah still pie pads cream as
currency is is did you ever see what was
that comedy special uh where it's John
early I think and and they're in a
universe where oh yeah what do they have
to pay with currency is melted caramels
yeah like scalding melted caramel
scales and like heat lamps so they can
melt their caramel to pay for things
that's what this sounds like that's
great yeah check that out if you haven't
um you never had a steampunk face on I
can imagine you in a stone pipe hat no I
know would it kill you to laugh with
Kate berland and John early that's the
company
um so yeah you'll catch Lon and I in
that dirigible with with two stove
pipettes yeah
Monicals and I'll have to do that that
handlebar thing with my mustache
uh good times so it's time to uh leave
you with a clue
um for next week's honest trailer as we
said it's one of the three worst
superhero things um certainly of the
calendar year
um but it's it's a top ten for me
Alzheimer just in terms of how it is
um and uh you can't do it I didn't like
it and I hope it burns inhale
but you can't be sure exactly what it is
next week oh who's to say what it is but
you'll probably guess because it's not
very good uh that's your clue uh we'll
see you then thanks so much for watching
bye-bye
[Music]